l'école européenne de cybersécurité de
versailles c'est une formation qui a
comme objectif de former des opérateurs
en cybersécurité entreprend des gens qui
n'ont pas du tout de passer
informatiques qui sont des débutants
complets et en deux ans de scolarité on
les amène un diplôme officiel d'étape
qu'on appelle un titre rncp d'opérateurs
en cybersécurité
l'objectif de le cs de versailles c'est
de former ces gens là et les gens qui
vont passer dans notre école vous
rentrez donc dans cette chaîne et de
manière certaine on peut affirmer que
les gens qui parce qu'on dans l'école ne
seront plus jamais au chômage après
pourquoi il ya une telle urgence parce
qu'en fait c'est ça la guerre de demain
c'est pas forcément une guerre 100%
militaire comme on peut la voir dans nos
livres d'histoire c'est une guerre qui
ne se voit pas qui est une guerre
numérique
l'idée ça va être de présenter à des
jeunes un parcours de dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité est ce qu'on appelle le
cyber combattants on va à leur montrer
un film qui n'a pas été montré au grand
public qui est en fait une film
d'animation sur une opération spéciale
qui concerne justement un pirate
informatique et on leur présent puisque
c'est un parcours complet deux
employeurs possible c'est à dire le
commandement de la cybersécurité de la
gendarmerie nationale qui sera présente
et le commandement de la cyber défense
de l'état major des armées